AND THE BRITISH ARE TEARING
THROUGH THE COLONIES.
BLAP, BLAP.
KGGH!
SYBIL LUDINGTON
JUST HAD HER 16TH BIRTHDAY.
HER DAD, HENRY LUDINGTON, IS
THE HEAD OF THE LOCAL MILITIA,
FENDING OFF THE BRITISH.
SO ON THIS PARTICULAR NIGHT,
SHE'S TUCKING IN HER BROTHERS
AND SISTERS,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
KA-KA, KA-KA.
THERE'S A KNOCK ON THE DOOR.
THIS MAN IS AT THE DOOR--
OH, MY GOD.
HE'S SO OUT OF BREATH.
THE BRITISH ARE BURNING
DANBURY, CONNECTICUT.
OKAY. OKAY,
SO HENRY LUDINGTON IS LIKE,
I NEED TO GO KNOCK
ON EVERY DOOR,
GET OUR MILITIA,
AND SAVE OUR COUNTRY.
WELL, HERE'S THE THING THOUGH.
I HAVE TO STAY HERE TO,
LIKE, RALLY THE TROOPS,
AND MAKE THE PLAN.
IT'S NOT LIKE YOU CAN
SEND AN E-VITE OUT.
SO WHO'S GONNA DO IT?
I'LL DO IT,
COMES A PEEP FROM THE NIGHT.
HEY.
BLAH BLAH.
I GOT IT.
SYBIL COMES PEEP-PEEP-PEEPING
DOWN THE NIGHT,
AND HER DAD'S LIKE,
SHE'S 16 YEARS OLD.
SHE'S A GIRL.
IT'S A [bleep]
HARD-ASS NIGHT OUTSIDE.
IT'S 40 MILES.
WELL, [bleep].
WE DON'T HAVE A BETTER OPTION.
SO YEAH,
WE'RE GONNA LET HER DO IT.
SHE SETS OUT INTO THE NIGHT.
SO GUESS WHAT HAPPENS.
IT STARTS RAINING.
WELL, SNAP.
IT'S RAINING.
IT'S, LIKE, WIND-Y TRAILS
AND BOULDERS.
SHE GRABS A STICK, AND
SHE'S--CHA-CHA--WHACKING IT
ON ALL THE DOORS
SHE PASSES BY.
KA-KA-KA.
SHE'S LIKE,
THE BRITISH ARE COMING!
IF YOU--THE BRITISH ARE COMING!
YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW ME.
COME BACK TO THE LUDINGTON'S.
AND IF YOU'RE NOT COMING,
THEN YOU'RE A MOTHER[bleep].
GO! GO! GO!
THIS IS THE MOMENT
WHERE I'M LIKE,
"OH, I REALLY AM DRUNK."
[giggles]